art
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comment retrouver la magie du chambord
des rois de france
ce château qui a gardé tout son mystère
[Musique]
imaginé par françois 1er qui l'a fait
bâtir il y a cinq cents ans
dans un contexte aussi de 4 118 501 dix
neuf ou françois premier rêve à l'
empire et forcément ça crée une ambiance
à créer une dimension une aura et ce
château est construit dans ce contexte
là de son contexte de toute puissance du
roi de france en europe
[Musique]
il
recréer évoqué questionner comment
vivaient-ils ces rois qui ont traversé
chambord en courant d'air le décorateur
jacques garcia a imaginé une atmosphère
un décor pour le château un travail long
et minutieux effectué par les artisans
de l'atelier des carmes près de paris
pour faire de chaque visiteur un invité
du roi
on a l'impression aujourd'hui que
chambord évident pour tous cas dans ces
espaces là mais c'était le cas la
plupart du temps sauf que quand le roi
venait il se remplissait le château se
remplissait parfois pendant deux ou
trois jours il y avait des convois qui
arrivait de blois et on mettait des
tentures sur les murs on mettait une
tapisserie et on mettait des meubles
puisqu'il faut se souvenir que mobilier
ça vient de mobiles
il faut pas imaginer que ces remplis
d'oeuvres d'art de tableau de ce statut
d'objets précieux de meubles trop
fragiles non plus c'est un mobilier qui
est essentiellement utilitaire qui est
fait pour être transporté donc pas trop
lourd trop encombrant de préférence
pliant ou démontable c'est encore mieux
puis par trop fragile dans l'entrée sud
les tentures réchauffe le blanc de la
pierre de tuffeau et orientent leurs
regards vers le monumental escalier à
double révolution
on voulait raconter une autre histoire
qui nous relie à tous les châteaux de la
loire et beaucoup de lui en france qui
est l histoire de la cour itinérante ce
que le gouvernement se déplaçait et elle
est de pays en pays en france et le roi
n'était pas le fixe c'est plus tard avec
versailles que le roi s'est fixé à un
endroit l époque la cour ne résidait pas
à paris
[Musique]
françois 1er va bouger constamment il va
rarement resté plus de deux mois trois
mois dans un endroit
et beh c'est l'un des premiers rois à
avoir fait pratiquement le tour de
france parce que deux fois dans
certaines régions et il est dans une
logique à la fois peut-être de bougeotte
personnel ça on n'en sait rien c'est
assez facile comme explication
l'explication autres elle est aussi de
rassurer la population face à toutes les
guerres qu'il peut faire continuellement
à ses besoins d'argent continue elle est
donc allée j'allais dire voir les son
peuple et bien c'est aussi une manière
pour lui à la fois de se faire
reconnaître les tapissière de l'atelier
des carmes joue les acrobates pour
habiller les murs jusqu'au plafond avec
des panneaux de 5 mètres de hauteur et
beaucoup de confection en atelier en
amont beau travail en amont mais qu'on
adapte aussi sur place en fonction du
tomber et du rendu du tissu de la
lumière de tout ce qui est en fait
autour de ce décor qu'on a conçu en fait
finalement sur papier à plat mais qui
prend vie différemment aussi sur place
les gens qui bougent
lumières qui joue le soleil qui change
les volets qui se ferme voilà
donc là on à l'entrée sud que l'on a
terminé donc on a on a tous eu voilà ce
qu a annoncé vers le jardin où il y en
avait peut-être de serre voilà ça c'est
les entrées de porte avec les à
saint-ouen l'atelier des carmes vit
depuis plusieurs mois au rythme de
chambord au départ j'y croyais pas trop
parce que c'est c'est pour moi c'était
fantastique un sa couronne 30 ans de
deux d'artisanat ça fait à peu près
trente ans que j'ai monté la société
donc c'est vraiment le un aboutissement
pour moi je trouve que c'est un travail
formidable dans un lieu magique un toute
façon malgré les dimensions imposantes
des tentures on a respecté les
contraintes des tapissière du 16e siècle
à l'époque il n'existait que des métiers
à tisser
deux petites largeurs 70 ou 55 nos
tissus actuellement sont d'une moyenne
de 140 160 donc on recrée des coutures
pour bien définir pour bien remontrer
que c'était des petites largeurs on est
toujours dans le même esprit de l'époque
en fait on a déjà fait le premier
panneau on va faire le deuxième le plus
grand en fait bien sûr dividendes en
trois panneaux et puis quand on sera là
où on a donc un peu de couture à la main
normal mais c'est long mais le résultat
est beau le coup parce que comme cette
première partie qu'on a déjà réalisé ce
le résultat est quand même assez de la
couleur
les mascaras en haut ça va pas être
énorme entre le lambrequins
[Musique]
sur chambord il n'ya rien alors on a des
choses dans d'autres châteaux puisque
vous savez que françois 1er est
intervenu sur 11 châteaux ou alors parce
qu'il les a construits véritablement ex
nihilo
c'est le cas de chambord c'est le
premier d'ailleurs ou alors parce qu'il
les a reconfiguré c'est le cas de loi
pas très loin d'ici
dès le début de son règne mais on n'a
rien sur sa vie véritablement à l'époque
il ya pas un peintre ou un grave un
dessinateur qui serait venu pour faire
quelques croquis donc c'est
véritablement une forme de
reconstitution les séjours de louis xiv
en revanche ont laissé quelques
souvenirs
le plus célèbre est sans doute le
théâtre de molière qui retrouve aussi sa
place dans le nouveau décor
ça donne du sens à l'intérieur du
château
c'est à alton cette dimension
diachronique comme on dit c'est à dire
qui rend témoignage des différentes
époques où le château a été habité
utiliser et quand on imagine que le
bourgeois gentilhomme a fait sa première
ici effectivement c'est quand même assez
émouvant
sévère que voulez-vous les écrire non
non pas de verre voulait que la non non
je le veux les pauses libère le théâtre
de molière permet de comprendre que
l'itinérance de louis xiv était plus
longue et que donc comme ils restaient
plus longtemps
il lui fallait des divertissements c'est
la raison pour laquelle molière venais
pour jouer de nouvelles pièces mais
aussi d'anciennes molière à sont
beaucoup plus jouer corneille que
molière ici à chambon
[Musique]
dernière phase du chantier la chambre de
françois 1er
je disais je veux servir mon seigneur
les tentures vont recouvrir entièrement
les murs et le lit du roi sera
reconstituée
les défauts fait un petit peu astucieux
parce que ça se passe jamais comme comme
sur le plan on improvise attaques à
peine 11 largeur me trois des quatre
pieds 60 la bande des quatre onces par
50% 1/3 juste alors dans l'angle mort la
com à rien les droits ont voulu tricher
quoi mais bon c'est aussi l'intérêt
c'est d'arriver à faire quelque chose là
on fait à peu près droit sans être droit
en fait dans la chambre prendront place
aussi les lits des courtisans et des
gardes leroy n'aimez pas la solitude
[Musique]
le petit comité d'un roi de france reste
quand même un gros comité 1 et ils
voyagent ils aient jamais seul il a
toujours forcément un entourage une
partie des gens de son hôtel quelquefois
son conseil pas toujours et puis aussi
forcément lagarde qui qui l'entourent
parce qu'il ya cette sécurité
donc on est toujours autour de deux
cents 200 250 personnes minimum
[Musique]
c'est un château de chasse exclusivement
au départ qu'il devient autre chose sans
perdre également son identité de château
de chasse il faut comprendre chambord
comme un château qui a plusieurs
significations qui s'empilent les unes
sur les autres
si on dit que ja de chambord est un
château politique c'est vrai mais ça
n'empêche qu'il est aussi un château à
destination spirituelle qu'il est aussi
un château à destination peut-être
presque cabalistiques mais qu'il est
également un château à destination
cynégétique toutes ses significations ne
se ne se noient pas se contredisent pas
les unes les autres
elles marchent ensemble
[Musique]
les divertir le roi tous les jours ou
presque joue avec dès qu'il le demande
est en tout cas et donc belges ont
construit extrait pour molière avec
molière une scène de théâtre dans le
château sur mon vieux sur mesure la
classe non
[Musique]
ce château comme beaucoup de monuments
en fait d'ailleurs n'est pas simplement
exclusivement liée à une époque il
continue à vivre après et il vit jusqu'à
nous en fait aujourd'hui le chambord
qu'on voit aujourd'hui on le voit avec
nos yeux et notre culture du 21e siècle
et au fond il me semble que c'est très
intéressant pour le public de pouvoir
justement faire certains faire cette
traversée de l'histoire de france du 16e
jusqu'au 21e siècle
chambord est restée la seule résidence
royale à n'avoir jamais subi de
transformations depuis sa création
[Musique]
chambord et ses énigmes qui en a
vraiment dessiné les plans qui faisaient
exactement françois 1er des questions
qui ont donné lieu à de multiples
interprétations
[Musique]
c'est tout le problème de l'histoire et
des historiens c'est toujours vouloir
combler les trous c'est toujours pouvoir
crier trouver les liens et toujours
peut-être à tort de croire que
finalement cette chaîne est une chaîne
continue elle et que on a pu penser il
ya cinq siècles les mêmes choses que
l'on peut penser aujourd'hui par rapport
à la définition de l'homme par rapport à
la définition du progrès à la parade
font du bien et du mal françois 1er qui
lisent à l' architecture pour s'adresser
à ses contemporains chambord est un
langage qui n'a cessé de s'enrichir au
fil des siècles
[Musique]